great music does more than enhance a
film it cements our memories in the film
going experience
I mean imagine the Godfather without its
iconic theme or Breakfast at Tiffany's
without the music of Henry Mancini or
the wondrous themes in music of John
Williams in Star Wars and here are the
nominees for the best original score'
the grand budapest hotel by alexander
there's black the theory of everything
by Johann Johansson interstellar by Hans
Zimmer mr Turner
bye Gary Gershom the imitation game with
my Alexander desk life the Oscar goes to
Alexandre Desplat the grand Budapest
hotel
oh well merci merci beaucoup
Wes you're a genius it is good you are
for me a great view from the grand
Budapest thank you it's been a beautiful
decade for me in Hollywood I worked with
great directors and producers and I'm
very grateful I need to thank Laura
angle my Graham Katz my great mother
sorry I met you long ago for my first
session and you play the violin and you
made everything happen for me so